coming up on swype hacking health I meet
the man who plans on living till he's a
hundred and eighty will tries out a
headband designed to sharpen the senses
and we join a Sherlock Holmes
investigation in our games review hello
and welcome to swipe this week were
inside the advanced hack zone at
Imperial College London we're here to
test an invention that can conduct sound
through bone more on that later but
first let's talk about biohacking which
is basically experimenting with science
and technology to enhance your body and
mind the trend even has its own
celebrity figures and when one of them
dropped into London recently of course I
was going to grab him for an interview
Dave Asprey probably the world's most
famous biohacker if he heard of
bulletproof coffee the diet the books
the supplements he's the guy behind them
I'm wearing a mask here that's full of
LEDs his entire brand including his top
ranking health podcast is all about
reaching a state of high performance
it's a biohacking career that began when
he was an overweight tech entrepreneur
in 1990s Silicon Valley I was 26 I made
six million dollars I lost it when I was
28 but when you're fat and tired all the
time nothing else matters so what I
ended up doing was applying all of the
knowledge I had from working in tech to
turn it around so that I could lose 100
pounds but most importantly I could have
this level of energy and focus that I'd
never had even as a teenager I started
recording my energy levels i started
testing what different foods did to me
and i started testing what kinds of
exercise worked I started meditating I
went to Tibet and I learned how to
meditate from the Masters I started
attaching computers to my head using
neurofeedback going as far back as the
late 90s and what I found is that
there's a rich source of data on the
human body and that if you just pay
attention you'll find that something you
did four hours ago or two days ago
affects your ability to be as you are in
the world today
in a nutshell how much money did you
spend over how long and what kind of
results did you end up achieving I spent
three hundred thousand dollars over
about 15 years and now it's closer to
probably a million dollars I lost a
hundred pounds of fat i can pay
attention I have more focus my IQ is
measurably higher than it used to be
these are big claims but they're born by
science you can actually do these things
everyone can do these things pour the
coffee gently and slowly through the
grounds Dave's diet challenges 1980s
attitudes towards fat he's the guy who
started the u.s. craze of adding butter
to coffee you can see this butter is a
yellow color this is because it's butter
from cows that a grass foods aside
though technology is key to his
biohacking I give us your top three tech
hacks I use a filter on my iPhone it's
called the zen tech filter and what it
does is it filters out the narrow
spectrum of light that affects your
sleep so a little bit of blue lights can
turn down melatonin so you don't get
sleep at night when you look at your
phone you're ruining your sleep hormones
that's not okay and this didn't happen
five years ago because our phones didn't
have bright white screens on them so
just by making that little change and by
dimming the lights in my house I sleep
better my kids sleep better it's a
complete game changer we glue electrodes
to your head and your brain makes an
electrical signal we play the signal
through a computer and then play it back
to you when we play your brain waves
back to you it lets your brain see what
it's doing for the first time and for
you it gives you better emotional
control and it lets your brain work
better the third thing is very very
available and it's called heart rate
variability training and this is a
little thing that clips on your ear or a
chest strap and it doesn't actually look
at how fast your heart rate beads it
looks at the spacing between your
heartbeats when I work with clients I
can teach them to get out of that
fight-or-flight mode consciously and on
purpose in about six weeks now as you'd
imagine days techniques and advice have
come in
criticism here's what he said when I
suggested he's leading his matters of
followers into dangerous experimentation
what I'm doing is I'm showing people
based principles so they can develop the
things that work for them and when I
talk about something that's dangerous I
really do my best to warn people and say
this can hurt you you need to go with
the professionals help on the flip side
though when we leave this up to doctors
nothing happens they do not innovate at
a rate that's acceptable I'm planning to
live to 180 years old and I'm not
kidding about that I'm not going to
count on doctors with their incredibly
slow rate of fearful innovation well
that told me then stick around for some
free running in our games review that's
coming up in just a moment here at
Imperial the researchers are known for
their pioneering work in science and
technology Will's been having a go on
one device designed to turn what we see
into something we can hear because we
want to put this headband on how do i
secure this and make sure it's working
properly that the creator's behind this
headset claim it could give us an extra
sense sauna send sound vibrations
directly through the skull so you don't
need to use headphones and once you're
hooked up the audio is manipulated to
sound like it's coming from any
direction or distance this could be
handy if you're a cyclist instead of
stopping to look at a mapping app it
here instructions in your skull head off
in the direction they're coming from you
can sense not only static locations of
things but how things are moving past
un's you would be able to hear this car
that is speeding up and approaching from
one side and be able to get out of the
way if you needed to at the moment this
is just a prototype but the technology
within it has huge potential
particularly for people who are visually
impaired you can guide someone not only
left and right but also front and back
and you can give some direction on
information you can have them
understanding better certain signals
that come from the phone all of this
without having an occluded ear canal now
this device here is called sub pack just
like sana it transmits sound through the
body at the moment it's being used for
virtual reality gaming and music
but it could also be used for many other
things for people with hearing problems
this could help them to enjoy music as
we focus on on low end and the
physicality of the music it allows
people who are on the hard-of-hearing
spectrum to really engage with music and
whole new way physicality meaning you
can actually feel it rather than just
hear it and so it's just kind of like a
whole new experience really inventions
like sub pack and sauna are definitely
fun to use but will they ever have mass
appeal it depends on the order
experience if it does improve things
dramatically then you'll always find a
market high-end headphones that cost
thousands of pounds still find a market
even though do we need them not really
people that want to have the extra
ability that different different
experience will always look for
something like that so yeah it could
catch on maybe not mass market everyone
we use them but definitely there will be
anisha people that want to buy this
stuff wearing an electronic headband is
unlikely to catch on with everyone but
prototypes like this might just signal
the start of a sound revolution will
sergeant nice going is creating it yeah
now this week's games review certainly
has a variety we've got fighting in
dungeons a freerunning first person and
some good old-fashioned detective work
Here's Lucy sure come to devil's
daughter is the latest in sort of a
long-running series of Sherlock Holmes
games it's not quite the you know the
Robert Downey jr. Sherlock Holmes it's
definitely at the Benedict Cumberbatch
either it's their own interpretation
he's a little bit younger and the game
is full of action and of course
investigating and being the world's
greatest detective so you control
Sherlock and you go through five cases
and you have to investigate them from
start to finish so you have to pick up
clues interrogate suspects it's a little
more action in the previous game so
there's a lot more brawling there's a
lot more gunplay but if you find a
Sherlock Holmes if you find a puzzle
games in general I recommend this
meros edge came out in 2008 and didn't
really set the world on fire but EA
thought it deserved a second chance
because the premise of the game is so
interesting so that's where we are with
Mirror's Edge catalyst so it's basically
a whole reimagining of the 2008 game
it's the same protagonist it's a lady
named faith and she's in the city of
glass and basically a giant evil
conglomerate has taken it over so faith
is a runner and she and her fellow
runners are trying to escape the
conglomerates evil clutches by doing
that they have to basically park all
over rooftops and deliver messages
across the city so that's what you do so
even if you didn't play the original
Mirror's Edge Mirror's Edge catalyst is
basically wiping the slate clean and I
think it's definitely worth looking
everyone loves a dungeon crawler so
super dungeon Bros is a definite one
each try out came a couple years ago and
peace even as being brought to ps4 you
can play a team of four online you can
also play with people who are playing on
a different console so if you're on ps4
you can close people who are on PC and
basically the four of you band together
take out some evil skeletons and it's
kind of fantasy meets hard rock but it's
a lot of fun you and your fellow players
can like team up and do special tax you
get awesome weapons like crossbows and
hammers so if you enjoy kind of just
dungeon reading games like that
well that's it for this week take a look
at sky names on mobile tablet catch up
like you and flapjack all the latest
tech stories throughout the week I'll
see you again next time bye bye